imagine if you will that two world
leaders are fighting a proxy war and one
of those leaders remembers every
historical event since ad. 862 in
meticulous detail and the other leader
can't remember when he was vice
president 8 years ago this you would
agree would not be an ideal situation
for citizens of the latter leaders
country and sadly both sides of that
hypothetical were on full display last
night I'm Michael nlls this is the
Michael nlls
[Music]
show welcome back to the show we have a
huge show today we have a ton to get
through and we've got I believe the very
first interview with our buddy the
pro-life Spider-Man M Des Mason will be
on the show later today he just climbed
the Las Vegas sphere days ahead of the
Super Bowl and was arrested and is being
charged with felony we'll get to all of
that in a moment he was doing that to
raise money for a pregnant woman because
he's the pro-life Spider-Man and
speaking of money you ought to check out
Birch gold text Nolls to 9898 98 we are
experiencing a lot of global instability
as we plunge into primary season North
Korea is testing missiles Ron is
becoming increasingly aggressive what
are you doing to protect your family in
the midst of all this chaos a great
place to start is by protecting your
savings it's not too late to invest in
gold with Birch gold group today unlike
many other Investments gold is viewed as
a safe haven during turbulent times
because it provides a hedge against
inflation and economic uncertainty Birch
gold will help you convert your existing
Ira or 401K into a tax shelter Ira in
Gold it won't cost you a penny out of
pocket while diversification does not
eliminate risk entirely vir Golds
experts can help you manage and reduce
providing a more resilient foundation
for your financial well-being I
encourage you to talk to one of their
trusted experts today text nolles kwes
to 98 9898 for a free info kit with an
A+ rating with the Better Business
Bureau countless five star reviews
thousands of happy customers check out
Birch gold today text noes kwes to 98
9898 claim your free info kit protect
your savings with gold that is nolles kW
to 98
9898 before I get to the Tucker
interview with Vladimir Putin before I
get to the disastrous Biden press
conference before I get to the supreme
court hearing the Colorado case about
why they want to kick Trump off the
ballot there they don't even want him to
appear on the ballot in Colorado and
Justice Clarence Thomas totally
destroyed that liberal lawyer before we
get to any of that the special counsel
report has come out there was a special
counsel investigating Joe Biden because
Joe Biden improperly handled classified
documents the same thing that they're
trying to put Trump in an orange
jumpsuit for Joe Biden did with less
authority to do it because when he
mishandled those documents he was not
the president of the United States he
did not have ultimate declassifying
Authority he had a lot more documents
and a lot more places it would seem and
uh uh finally we've gotten a result from
this special Council and the result
is Joe
Biden did all the stuff that they
accused Trump of doing frankly did a
more egregious version of all the stuff
that they accuse Trump of doing but
because he is so old and scile they are
not going to prosecute him because he is
basically not fit to stand trial he will
not be prosecuted according to special
counsel Robert her Biden quote willfully
retained and disclosed classified
materials so why aren't they going to
prosecute him because quote we have also
considered that at trial Mr Biden would
likely present himself to a jury as he
did during our interview of him as a
sympathetic well-meaning elderly man
with a poor
memory it would have been brutal to
Biden had the special counsel actually
prosecuted him and put him on trial and
that was never going to happen in a way
this report is almost more brutal
because they're saying the guy basically
can't remember his own name that these
the reason they're not Prosecuting him
is because it would be like Prosecuting
a child or an animal you know this is
someone who's just not in command of his
rational faculties the special Council
goes on based on our direct interactions
with and observations of him he is
someone for whom many jurors will be
able to identify reasonable doubt it
would be difficult to convince a jury
that they should convict him by then a
former president well into his 80s of a
serious felony that requires a mental
state of willfulness the man who is
currently running for reelection as
president of the United States as
multiple Wars are breaking out the that
could lead to a global conflict war in
Ukraine war in the Middle East an open
border with with a flood of millions and
millions of foreign Nationals pouring
into our
country the
president does not have a mental state
of
willfulness according to the special
counsel Biden's memory was worse during
an interview with him than it was in
recorded conversations that go back to
2017 and when I say worse I don't mean
like he he didn't remember the details
of some Senate negotiation from 1978
when he was when he was first elected to
the Senate back in the 70s I'm not
talking about the 70s or the 80s or the
90s or even really the
2000s I mean quote he did not remember
when he was vice president forgetting on
the first day of the interview when his
term
ended apparently this is the direct
quote if it was 2013 when did I stop
being vice
president direct quote from the report
and forgetting on the second day of the
interview when his term began in 2009 am
I still vice
president direct quote he also did not
remember when his son Bo died he also
did not remember a debate about
Afghanistan he did not remember even
within several years when his son died
so I see why they would say he's a
sympathetic person
I I've had grandparents who have gone
through this kind of mental decline many
of you have had grandparents or parents
that have gone through this kind of
mental decline you know exactly what
this is like and especially if you know
an elderly person who's experienced some
kind of trauma like a child dying it can
be very disorienting it can accelerate a
a a kind of a mental decline but when we
say oh he's he's losing a step or two
we're not talking about him speaking a
little bit more slowly or taking a
moment to remember certain dates and
numbers we're talking about he doesn't
remember within years some of the most
important events of his
life he doesn't remember when he served
as vice
president absolutely brutal so that's
the president of our country
then the hours after that special
Council report came out we saw the
president of another country whom many
call our number one geopolitical
adversary that would meet President
Vladimir Putin doing an interview with
Tucker
Carlson the interview was spectacular
Tucker did a great job Vladimir Putin
did a great job Vladimir Putin Begins
the interview by answering Tucker's
simple question namely why did you
invade Ukraine with a roughly 12200 year
history of Russia and Ukraine and
Lithuania and Poland involving persons
involving specific years in involving
pivotal Events off the top of his head
from
memory let's look where our relationship
with Ukraine started from where did
Ukraine come
from the Russian State started Gathering
itself as a centralized
statehood and it is considered to be the
year of the establishment of the Russian
state in
862 when the town's people of no invited
a varangian prince ruri from Scandinavia
Terrain in 1862 Russia celebrated the
1,000th anniversary of its
statehood and in no there is a Memorial
dedicated to the 1,000th anniversary of
the
country I'm I'm just playing a very tiny
piece of this uh it goes on for about
half an hour during most of the time
Tucker has just got perfect Tucker face
looking at Putin you like uh huh and
he'll interrupt occasionally because
Tucker said well I feared he was just
trying to
filibuster but then I realized he wasn't
trying to filibuster Vladimir Putin
realizes that no one in the west knows
any of this history certainly of that
region we don't know much history about
our own region and our own country
anymore and if you want to understand
modern political events it helps to have
historical context we've just totally
forgotten our history we think that
history began yesterday this is a
consequence of liberalism political
liberalism which denigrates the past it
says the past doesn't really matter has
a utopian view of the future they're not
very liberal over there in Russia
they're not liberal in China they're not
liberal in most parts of the world it's
it's a particularly American and more
broadly Western
phenomenon Putin was extremely
impressive last
night but it's not that Putin is the
greatest Statesman who's ever lived he's
a very talented Statesman there is no
question about
that we used to have Statesmen like this
too we used to have Statesmen who had
studied history who understood
geopolitics and Grand strategy who had a
realistic view of how Nations develop we
we used to have that and we lost that
somewhere but we that did exist in the
West
even in recent American memory Richard
Nixon could talk like this frankly to
some degree George W bush could talk
like this he he didn't Putin makes this
point in the interview he says you know
people all made fun of bush for for
talking like an idiot but Bush was
actually a pretty sophisticated thinker
and he and I would have pretty serious
conversations but someone like a Nixon
could could talk like this Eisenhower
could talk like
this earlier Statesmen understood
statecraft now we don't now for us it's
all just kind of a joke joke it's all
just shallow modern political ideologies
this kind of talk though everyone wants
to say Putin is's the worst guy ever
he's just Hitler 2.0 what you know
everyone every bad person is Hitler so
say the people who don't even know that
much about Hitler you know every
historical event is the fall of Rome
these are people who don't even know
that much about the fall of Rome it's so
profoundly shallow and it seems to me
that if you want to understand and
perhaps uh work your way out of a
political conflict that might threaten
World War II it helps to see things from
the other person's point of view isn't
that what the Liberals tell us all the
time you just need to understand
everyone else's point of view and walk a
mile in their shoes except when it comes
to our geopolitical
adversaries with whom we're currently
engaging in a proxy war I don't think so
very impressive stuff then Putin moves
on to the current justification for the
war in Ukraine which we'll get to in one
second though but first when you want to
see into someone's mind may you talk to
them you see things from their point of
view when you want to see into your home
you need to get Windows from Renewal by
Anderson text nolles to 200 300 if your
house feeling a little chilly right now
you might want to consider window
replacements now I know I get it for
most homeowners window replacement is
not something that you've ever done
before and it might seem like a daunting
task well luckily there's a company that
will do the work for you Renewal by
Anderson is your One-Stop shop for
window design manufacture and
installation Windows play a crucial role
in regulating indoor temperatures if you
notice a spike in your heating or
cooling bills it might be due to
inefficient windows don't put it off any
longer Renewal by Anderson these guys
are the best in the country they've got
limited fully transferable and best in
the nation warranty coverage I've heard
from a carpenter who wrote in
unsolicited said I heard you mention
Reno by Anderson they do the best work
that I see I got a cousin who works for
these guys and has raved about them for
years long before they came on to
support the show right now Renewal by
Anderson is offering a free in home
consultation on quality energy efficient
Affordable Windows or patio doors with
special financing options text nolles to
200 300 for a free consultation to buy
one window or door and get 40% off plus
you'll get 200 bucks off your entire
purchase these savings won't last long
be sure to check it out by texting
nolles to 200 300 text nlls to 200 300
texting privacy policy in terms and
conditions posted to text. us texting en
rolls for recurring automated text
marketing messages message dat rates may
apply reply stop top. minimum purchase
required interest Ur from dat to
purchase but is waved if paid within
promotional period go to window
appointment now.com for full offer
details Putin then in the second part of
the interview gets to the argument for
going into Ukraine today and that would
be
densification we haven't achieved our
aims yet because one of them is the
nazification this means the prohibition
of all kinds of Neo-Nazi movements what
is denazification what would that mean
what you say Hitler has been dead for so
many years 80 years but his example
lives on people who exterminated Jews
Russians and Poes are alive and the
president the current president of
today's Ukraine applauds him in the
Canadian Parliament gives a standing
ovation can we say that we have
completely uprooted this ideology if
what we see is happening
today that is what the nification is in
our
understanding we have to get rid of
those people who maintain this concept
and support this practice and try to
preserve it that is what the nification
is this is a brilliant answer from Putin
because it's both extremely
cynical and has a profound degree of
truth to it it seems like those two
things are in Conflict but it's cynical
in that Putin knows that for the West
Nazism is the worst thing possible uh
the West no longer believes in God the
West no longer believes in the devil but
the West does believe in the Incarnation
of evil in the figure of a Mustachio
Austrian painter who became a German
dictator that is the symbol we we don't
believe in Devils anymore we we erect uh
statues of demons and Satan in our state
capitals ironically we we have
politicians giving impassionate speeches
on the rights of satanists okay but
there is a devil the replacement devil
is just Hitler so we know that is the
the the symbol of absolute evil in the
west and Putin says yeah Ukraine they're
they're Hitler people they're Nazi
people and that's why we want to denn
naify it's like saying we want to deevil
ify Ukraine he knows that's going to
play well in the west and Tucker says
well haven't you know haven't we had
enough Hitler like Hitler's been gone
for a long time and Putin says well what
about that Ukrainian soldier that was
applauded in Canada who who worked
worked with Hitler cuz if you're going
to fight if you're going to fight the
Russians in Ukraine in World War II that
means you're working with Hitler because
the War was between Hitler and the
Russians
okay now at a deeper level it's not just
cynical it's not just him playing on the
the talking points of the West because
he's saying that Ukraine has been a long
contested territory it was part of the
Polish Lithuanian wealth for a while it
was part of Russia for a while but then
in the 19th century and especially in
the 20th century there was a movement
for Ukrainian nationalism and
Independence around the same time that
you saw nationalist movements take take
hold all over the
world and this intensified during the
20th century during World War II and
so Nazism does become a an expression of
a Ukrainian national identity that's
anti-russian by the sheer historical
fact that the Nazis fought the Russians
in World War
II and we do know that there are some
Neo-Nazi elements in Ukraine like the
asov Battalion which has been much
written about so there's a there's a
real level here denazification of
Ukraine is an important priority for
Russia not just because the the mustache
man is evil but
because Nazism is an expression of
Ukrainian independence from the
Russians very subtle Point as there are
many subtle points from Vladimir Putin
and then I'm skipping over hours of
footage but Tucker then ends the
interview in a very bold way asking for
the release of a Wall Street Journal
journalist who is an American from
Russian prison here's Putin's answer I
just got to ask you one last question
and that's about someone who's very
famous in the United States probably not
here Evan gersovitz who's the Wall
Street Journal reporter he's
32 um and he's been in prisoned for
almost a year uh this is a huge story in
the United States and I just want to ask
you directly without getting into the
tals of it or your version of what
happened if as a sign of your decency
you would be willing to release him to
us and we'll bring him back to the
United States we have done so many
gestures of what good will out of
decency that I think we have run out of
them no we have never seen anyone
reciprocate to us in a similar
manner however in theory we can say that
we do not rule out that we can do
that if our partners take reciprocal
steps there is no taboo to settle this
issue we are willing to solve
it but there are certain terms being
discussed via special services
channels I believe an agreement can be
reached
another very good answer from Putin he
says look you know sometimes you get our
spies sometimes we get your spies the
CIA is talking to FSB we'll work it out
even the way he talks about the special
services remember Putin worked for the
KGB and he says I work for KGB I would
have uh conversations with my
counterparts In America which is Cia you
know it's a job it's very he's very
disarming in person he says maybe we
reach a deal but I'm not just giving you
your spy your American spy we're going
to get something out of it uh brutal
brutal interview Tucker did a great job
Putin did a great job The Establishment
media obviously didn't want you to see
this because it cuts through a lot of
propaganda and it and worse for them it
exposes them to be fake journalists who
don't actually spend a lot of time or
effort uh presenting facts so this all
would have been bad enough the special
counsel Report with the Putin interview
then almost inexplicably Biden decides
to hold a press conference a as
if you might not be certain that Biden
is mentally declining or declined he
says no no no I got to prove it so as
Putin is demonstrating his Acumen his
historical Precision his sophisticated
statesmanship Biden comes out and makes
a a big fool of himself now
the the press conference actually opened
up pretty well you can hear it here how
bad is your memory and can you continue
as president my memory is so bad I let
you
speak that's that's that's memory has
gotten worse Mr President my memory is
not got my memory is fine my memory take
a look at what I've done since I become
president so there were lots of terrible
answers from Biden here I actually
thought this answer was pretty good he
gets a question from I some conservative
reporter it sounds kind of like Peter
Ducey but I assume every conservative
reporter is Peter duy and he says how's
your memory Mr Biden Mr President and
and Biden says my memory is so bad that
I called on you that's a funny answer
that's actually kind of a Sharp answer
so his answers were not quite as bad as
people are saying even people are
sending a clip around where it's it
seems as though Biden is forgetting the
church that his son his late son Bo
attended I felt he was just getting kind
of choked up with emotion as one would
if one son had died and so that wasn't
so bad the the bad answers came when
when Biden confused uh Egypt and Mexico
the
conduct of the
response in Gaza in the Gaza Strip has
been
um over the
top I think that uh
as you
know initially the president of Mexico
CC did not want to open up the gate to
allow humanitarian material to get in I
talked to him I convinced him open the
gate I talked to BB to open the gate on
the Israeli side I talked to him I said
hey president CeCe
come
bibl and then he started speaking to me
in Arabic I had no idea that the
Mexicans even spoke farsy anywh who I
think we solved this uh Israel Sweden
problem you know On the Border I think
somewhere on the border of Israel and
Tibet we're going to finally solve the
illegal immigration crisis from
Nicaragua thank you very much not a good
answer that was that was a pretty bad
lapse and then when the Press calls him
out he he gets angry president for
months when you were asked about your
age you would respond with the words
watch me many American people have been
watching and they have expressed
concerns about your age that is your
judgment that is your judgment that is
not the Judgment of the
press uh no Mr President I am the Press
it's bad enough they say Mr President a
lot of people are concerned about your
age and he says no no that's your
judgment that answer could have been
okay it's still you don't want to be
seen as the angry orinary old man but
but then he goes on he says that's your
judgment that's not the Judgment of the
press oh wait you are the Press well let
me call up my my uh friend CeCe he's the
president of Canada and uh oh wait he's
huh where am I who's the president am I
the president really bad really bad uh
answers really embarrassing unsettling
just to see those two world leaders on
display very unsettling for us very sad
to see what's going on with Joe Biden uh
the big political takeaway from
me Democrats want to kick him out he
does not want to be kicked out there are
all these theories oh Gavin nome's going
to be the top of the ticket oh Michelle
Obama's going to replace him at the
convention unless this man is dead or on
his deathbed this man is not giving up
power maybe some Democrats want to
replace him doesn't matter this guy is
not going anywhere of his own valtion
they will have to wheel him out of the
White House Kicking and Screaming or
stiff as a board because he is not going
to chose to go anywhere now
speaking speaking of stiff as aboard you
got to check out hymns right now go to
hns.com did you know that 52% of men
over the age of 40 experience some form
of Ed with such a high percentage it is
strange that it's always been a taboo
topic hyms is changing men's Healthcare
by providing access to Affordable and
discreet health treatment all from the
comfort of your couch all all you need
to do is visit hims.com and answer a
series of questions on their site a
medical provider will determine the
right treatment option for you if
prescribed your medication will ship
directly to you for free and in discreet
packaging hims provides access to
clinically proven generic alternatives
to viager and Calis with options as low
as two bucks per dose no insurance is
needed he'll pay one low price for your
treatments online visits ongoing
shipments and provider messaging hims
has hundreds of thousands of trusted
subscribers so if Ed is something that
is getting you down it's time to change
that start your free online visit today
at hims.com hs.com
for your free ed treatment options
hs.com
canw today prescriptions require an
online consultation with a healthcare
provider who will determine if
appropriate restrictions apply see
website for details and important safety
information subscription required price
varies based on product and subscription
plan my favorite comment yesterday is
from Linda
cier uh 1670 who says how exactly does
one practice Satanism without Satan this
is the most blatant in-your-face lie
I've ever heard holy God protect us from
these people uh yes yeah we should pray
to God certainly and we should avoid
Satanism but the answer is pretty simple
actually because Satanism is not about
getting on your knees and bowing down in
worshiping Satan I guess ultimately it
is but the the means of Satanism has
always been the worship of the self so
if you asked most satanists throughout
history what do you worship they would
say the self I mean it goes back to the
Garden of Eden when Satan tells Eve ye
shall be his Gods it's about an
exaltation and a worship and an idolatry
of the self and that's what it is today
even when the the the edgy Reddit tier
atheists come out and they say you know
we don't actually worship Satan no you
stupid religious theistic idiots no we
just worship ourselves like uhhuh yeah
right that's that's how John Milton
describes it too that's how the Book of
Genesis describes it too neither of
which the edgy Reddit tier atheists have
read
uh I'm very much looking forward to
getting to the pro-life Spider-Man two
stories I've got to get to
First speaking of presidential elections
Clarence Tomas destroyed the liberal
lawyer in the Colorado election case
yesterday goes up to the Supreme Court
this is the state of Colorado insisting
uh that we we the states have the right
to kick a presidential candidate off the
ballot because of the 14th Amendment or
something Justice Thomas knocks it down
it would seem that particularly uh uh
after
reconstruction uh and after the
compromise of
1877 and during the period of redeemers
that you would have that kind of
conflict there were plethora of
Confederates still around there were any
number of people who would continue to
either run for State offices or national
offices so it seemed it that would
suggest that there would at least be a
few examples of uh national uh
candidates being uh
disqualified if your reading is correct
well there were certainly National
candidates who were disqualified by
Congress refusing to seat them I
understand that but that's not this case
I'm right there I love it that you know
right from this answer that Colorado's
got nothing that these liberals who want
to kick Trump off they've got nothing
say well um Justice I don't have any of
the sort of examples that you would are
asking me for but here's a totally
irrelevant example and Thomas having
none of it he goes yeah yeah I sure I
don't I don't care about what you
ordered at McDonald's last week buddy I
don't you don't need to uh recite the
Poetry of Robert Frost to me I'm asking
for a very specific answer that pertains
to the very specific legal argument you
guys are making namely that the states
have the right based on the 14th
Amendment to boot political candidates
they don't like like off the ballot so
can you give me any example we know that
this is a Reconstruction Era provision
of the 14th Amendment to to stop the
Confederates from taking over the
country so that would be the time when
when this kind of provision would be
most exercised can you give me even one
single example of it ever being
exercised in the way you claim 150 years
later that you Colorado have a right to
do and the lawyer says uh
H did States disqualify them that's what
we're talking about here I understand
Congress would not suat them other than
the example I gave no states were
sending people uh the concern was that
the former Confederate states would
continue being bad actors and the effort
was to prevent them from doing this and
you're saying that well this also
authorized states to disqualify
candidates so what I'm asking you for if
you are right what are the
examples well your honor the examples
are States exclud included many
candidates for State office individuals
holding State offices we have yeah man I
know they the states do state things
sure and the federal government can
though they really didn't do federal
federal government things they the
Congress took some actions but then they
stopped taking those actions oh sure
okay but the case that you're bringing
buddy is arguing that the states can
disqualify a presidential candidate
based on the 14th Amendment so you're
doing a big soft shoe around this issue
can you give me one example no a number
of published cases of States consider
understand that I I understand the
states controlling State uh elections
and state positions what we are talking
about here are National candidates but
they did not think it's like justice
Thomas is explaining this to a
10-year-old he's say I he he's he's even
showing a great deal of of sympathy here
and compassion for this lawyer who is
being obtuse you know he probably knows
that he's got nothing so he's dancing
around it but if he is really just this
ignorant he's saying no I the states and
the federal government are
different and they're treated
differently by the law so the case
you're trying to make sir is X Y and Z
keep going I think about authorizing the
South to disqualify National candidates
and that's the argument you're making
and what I would like to know is you
give is uh do you have any examples of
this many of those historians have filed
briefs in our support in this case
making the point that the the idea of
the 14th amendment was that both States
and the federal government would ensure
rights and that if States failed to do
so the federal government certainly
would also step in so I don't think the
history tells us sort of look at Justice
Thomas's question sort of from the
30,000 foot level I mean the whole point
of the 14th Amendment was to restrict
state power right States uh shall not
abridge privileges immunity they won't
deprive people of property without due
process um they won't deny uh equal
protection and on the other hand it
augmented Federal power under Section
Five Congress has the power to enforce
it so wouldn't that be the last place
that you'd look for authorization for
the States including Confederate states
uh to enforce implicitly authorized to
enforce
the presidential election process that
that seems to be a position that is at
uh at war with the whole thrust of the
14th Amendment and very ahistorical oh
devastating because the person you hear
at the end there is Chief Justice John
Roberts who's kind of a Squish and he
sides with the libs a lot and even he's
coming in and he's saying yo Colorado
you got nothing man
actually the the provisions you're
citing would they would be the last
place you'd go to make the sort of
argument that you're making so this
happily this could be an this could be a
unanimous Supreme Court decision for all
we know because Colorado doesn't have a
leg to stand on could be 8 to one you
know maybe it's maybe either katoni
Jackson or
Sodor
uh side with Colorado maybe they're both
quite partisan maybe it's seven to2 but
I think I think it's pretty clear Trump
is is going to remain the nominee and I
think it's clear that Biden so long as
he can breathe is going to remain the
nominee and it's clear that V Vladimir
Putin is going to remain the president
of the Russian Federation and uh who do
you want going up against that guy I
have a pretty clear answer so much more
to get to but we've got to divert the
rest of those news stories because we
have actual news coming on the show that
would be my friend the pro-life
Spider-Man that would be Mason D Mason a
man who uh engages in these kind of
Daredevil Feats I mean climbing all
sorts of giant buildings and in this
case we're talking about the sphere in
Las Vegas just ahead of the Super Bowl
to raise money for pro-life causes and
to raise attention for pro-life causes
and he's a very impressive young man
Mason thank you for coming on the show
thank you for having me on Michael am I
right to understand you just got out of
jail last
night yeah yeah so it was a crazy
experience uh you know a lot of laws
were broken by the Las Vegas Police
Department they were detaining me for
over three hours without telling me what
crime I actually committed and while I
was in handcuffs in the back of the
police car they started debating uh
abortion so hopefully uh we can get some
lawyers and uh make the Las Vegas Police
Department a pretty large pro-life donor
wow you you say hopefully we can get
some lawyers do you do you currently
have a lawyer or are you in need of a
lawyer oh yeah I have defense lawyers uh
but I I think the way they broke laws I
mean they arrested every single person
that was on the ground for handing out
pamphlets there there there's this uh
charge that they like to give to Pro PR
lifers and it seems to only happen to
prol lifers it's the charge of
conspiracy I mean they had the worship
leader of my church at one point in
handcuffs I'm so glad my grandma didn't
come because they would have had my
grandma in handcuffs and honestly I'm a
little worried for you for just having
me on this show that they're going to
give you a conspiracy charge Michael
well we know that especially under Joe
Biden's Administration we know that the
uh cops at the federal level and at the
more local level are much tougher on
pro-lifers and we've seen prosecutions
via the face Act of you know pro-lifers
who were just praying around an abortion
clinic they'll be arrested for violating
this bogus 1990s law signed by Bill
Clinton uh we we know that they the feds
are going in kicking kicking at the
doors of pro lifers and arresting them
for for demonstrating outside of a
Planned Parenthood you know arresting
these guys in front of their seven kids
I mean just really egregious in yourface
kind of persecution of pro lifers so I'm
no surprised that they're going not
surprised at all rather that they're
going after you what is the charge
against
you they claim that I damaged over a
$100,000 of uh their building which is
not true at all uh when I got to the top
I planned on climbing down and they uh
got a socket wrench and uh took took off
one of the little panels for me to to
slide through and then immediately put
it back on you know they invited me
inside I took up their offer because
they had a police officer there and so
now we have a felony destru ction of
property charge uh and a conspiracy to
destroy property charge when I paid my
bail they took me to the release room
and then they immediately took me back
to another room because when the da saw
that we had paid the bail they slapped
another charge on and it wasn't until
yesterday morning that my bondsman had
seen it and luckily he's a Christian so
he paid the that bail too and got me out
of there uh we still have three people
who are in jail right now uh for holding
signs and handing out pamphlets
basically um but you know what I'll say
Michael is I was really happy that when
I got out of jail you know I I climbed
these buildings to raise money for women
and that's really where I want to keep
the focus on is helping these women and
and saving these babies and when I got
out of jail I saw that our fundraiser
was filled to the brim and it was a good
sign because it made me you know
reminded me that what we're doing this
for is is worth it we were able to save
a baby because we climbed some silly
building and uh you know so what we did
was we extended the fundraiser and so
all of the extra money that we raised
we're going to save another baby with So
when you say when you say you saved a
baby with it I know you do a ton of
pro-life work but in this what
specifically do you mean with this
climb yeah so let them live.org is based
around the statistic that 7 3% of women
who have abortions do it because of
financial circumstances and when you go
out in sidewalk Council in front of an
abortion clinic a lot of women they
simply just ignore you and walk into the
clinic and murder their children and
that's a sad thing is that a lot of
people seem to forget that these women
they're not going in there to clean
their teeth they're going in there to
murder their child so we have to do
anything and everything to keep them
from committing this mortal sin as well
as support them and save their child so
we offer them uh you know help with rent
uh we pay their medical bills we do
anything and everything they need to not
kill their child that's that's amazing
so is there is there a particular woman
in mind here with this climb or is it
just more generally for any woman that
you might encounter who has this
financial reasoning for why why they
would want to kill their
kid yeah so the woman were helping out
this time uh she is her name is Isabelle
she is 11 weeks pregnant and she was
homeless so we're getting her an
apartment we're getting her off the
streets and we're trying to get her a
job and uh just helping her out so that
she can be independent I'm not sure
whether she wants to keep the baby or
put the baby up for adoption but uh I'm
just happy that she's choosing life and
came to let them live and that enough
people were able to pitch in and and
help support her because you know sorry
go on the narrative is is that PR lifers
don't do anything to help these women
we're just uh you know Pro birth but
it's it's a bunch of baloney we we we
put our money where our mounts are more
than any other kind of issue or any
other movement of course you always hear
this though you you you're only Pro
fetus once the baby gets out you don't
care and you don't care about them and
it's just obviously uh undercut by all
of the charitable statistics all of the
the examples of the sort of work that
you were doing this appears to be the
most serious charge that has ever been
brought against you I mean you've been
detained after your climbs before but
most people just say okay you know no
big deal whatever those good stunt you
raise money for a good cause okay
bye-bye uh what are you facing I mean
are you facing jail time are you facing
some major fine or what what what does
this felony charge really look
like yeah you know I mean uh it's a
felony and and two gross misdemeanors I
I'm sure that they're going going to try
to slap more on uh luckily my lawyers
are going to take care of it I they
broke so many laws that I'm not worried
about the charges at all but that said
whether they want to throw me in jail
and that's what ends up
happening as long as we can save a baby
I'm not really too worried Michael
because like what's happening right now
in America is a holocaust it's over 70
million babies murdered since roie Wade
alone so if if me going to jail Saves a
Life that is literally the least that I
can
do it's a really powerful Point uh Mason
where can people support you either your
legal fees or uh the this woman Isabelle
these other women or all of the
above yeah they can go to letm live.org
and donate and then go follow me on
Instagram and YouTube and it's
pre.pdf the clink and they don't throw
you in an orange jumpsuit for having the
audacity to try to help a homeless woman
and save a baby uh what's the next climb
going to
be I don't know Michael I'm trying to
look for one that maybe you could come
with me on you know maybe I'll support
you from the bottom Mason I'll Have a
Cigar ready for you afterward but I
don't you know I was never the most say
it again the Mayflower cigar the
Mayflower cigar that'll be that'll be my
role we can all support and some of us
do the more bold and heroic actions some
of us play more of a supporting role so
I'll be there to uh give you a little uh
relaxing smoke after the climb I I just
hope whatever the next big building is
uh if if these awful liberal politicians
want to punish you for helping a baby I
hope you just climb right out of that
jail you know I want to see you sort of
climbing out like St Peter or St Paul
and uh and then you can continue your
very excellent work Mason thank you very
much for everything you do and stay stay
strong pal and we'll talk to you next
time thanks for having me on Michael
okay Valentine's Day is coming up
whether you are shopping for him or for
her Jeremy has the perfect gift to
surprise your better half from delicious
chocolate to smooth razors to the iconic
leftist te Tumblr to celebrate Jeremy's
offering a 20% discount on all
Valentine's Day bundles that's right 20%
off but you have to act fast because
today is the last day for express
shipping on time for Valentine's arrival
this offer is only here for limited time
go to Jeremy
racers.car Valentine's Day bundle the
best way to treat your Valentine and
yourself finally finally we've arrived
at my favorite time of the week when I
get to hear from you in the mailbag
mailbag is sponsored by Pure Talk
talk.com noes save an additional 50% off
your first month take it
away hi Michael it's the shuckmeister I
had a question about your brilliant
showing on the whatever podcast when you
go on to these types of show shows are
you ever concerned about bringing
yourself or your audience into the near
occasion of sin I love that you treat
all the women on the panel with dignity
and don't dunk on them for social points
but the women you talk to are all
dressed pretty provocatively speak about
topics that are intended to tempt
certain desires and there's a bunch of
links to very degenerate content in the
video description I appreciate that
you're taking the same approach as our
Lord who dined with Sinners and
prostitutes but said Sinners and
prostitutes weren't actively advertising
their unquote content to a wider
audience particularly people in the
creme de La Creme who I hope wouldn't
fall into those Temptations I'm not
trying to be the Purity police but it's
just something I'm genuinely curious
about and I wonder if there's a more
prudent way to engage with these people
let me know what you think thanks it's a
fear and I've thought of it uh but I
ultimately don't think it's too much of
a concern I I think it's it's still
worth going on whatever maybe some other
shows my chief goal when I go on a show
like the whatever podcast is to
convince these women to stop doing what
they're doing that's my chief immediate
goal more than any show I'm putting on
for the audience if I were just putting
on a show for the audience I would call
the women you know big dumb idiots and
as as perhaps some of the other guests
do on the show and probably then the
clips would go more viral my my chief
objective is to convince these women to
stop selling their bodies for sex
there then when one stops going in the
wrong direction one can then turn around
go in the right direction that's my
that's my next goal and then the uh
General goal of going on a a public
forum is to convince the other people
who are at home that if they're in the
woman's position they should stop doing
that or if they're in the position of
the consumer that they're like weird
creepy cucks for looking at pornography
and they should cut it out because it's
degrading to them and is harmful to the
women uh so to your point
does just even appearing on the show uh
does that tempt people to subscribe to
the girls you know only fans websites or
whatever I don't think in particular
because much of our
conversation chinks away at the facade
that they present on their pornography
websites so like to give an example I
was talking to some of these girls and
and they open up and they say hey
subscribe to my only fans we got really
hot content or you know I jiggle around
or whatever but but very quickly then
the girls admit oh actually I don't have
really good relationships with men and
oh actually I have a stalker now and
it's really dark and I'm not allowed to
use my real name and sometimes I get
kind of depressed about it and I I
really miss this person that I was in
love with and I'm I I can't get that
back and I actually my life isn't that
good and it's really kind of bad and
degraded
and it would seem to me that exposing
even porn customers or potential porn
customers to the reality of that is is
much much more likely to discourage them
from looking at the content than to
entice them to look at it but I agree
with you it's a uh concern and therefore
requires a credential judgment next
question hello my this
Elmo that's correct now Elmo doesn't
have a question for you Elmo just heard
that you don't know how to talk like
Elmo and everyone should talk like Elmo
so Elmo teach you it's very easy all you
have to do is constrict the back of your
throat you know your uula yeah you want
to send that up into the back of your
throat and then you just want to shut
off your nasal passages so that you
don't breathe through your nose that's
how you talk like El and just to give
you an example Elmo will reveal his real
voice so you can see that anybody can
talk like Elmo so this is Elmo's real
voice hello Michael nolles this is Elmo
and you just learned how to talk like
Elmo I hope you have a fantastic
day goodbye
now
hm that's not a bad lesson my only
criticism of your Elmo is it's vaguely
Hispanic
ELO Amo you know but otherwise it was a
very good one and you did help me to I
think improve my Elmo impression next
one hi Michael love love your show I'm
from Colorado and uh given the Supreme
Court deliberations and the likely
outcome that um will rule in favor of
trump do you think that they will unify
or divide the country thank you and
thank you very much for everything
you're doing very kind I think a court
decision even 72 but certainly 81 or 90
would unify the
country
even obviously virtually all Republicans
and most Independents and and even a
huge number of
Democrats believe that the prosecutions
of trump are politically motivated and
unjust
now we're not even talking about all the
prosecutions here we're just focused on
whether the state can kick a
presidential candidate off the ballot I
think that's a very very unpopular view
even among Democrats so I I think a
clear message from the Supreme Court
would help to unify even if the the a
lot of people still hate Trump or
whatever uh that is going to help to
unify the country it's a it's a low bar
because we're saying okay you can't just
willy-nilly kick people off of the
ballot uh but that' be a good step in
the right direction and I will take it
Super
Bowl
58 I'm told is this Sunday February 11th
but instead of being subjected to woke
commentary and discussions of Taylor
Swift every two seconds even though I
actually like Taylor Swift uh join crane
and& company's live stream to enjoy the
matchup they will be going live at 6:15
p.m. Eastern so tune in on daily War
Plus or The Crane and& Company YouTube
channel for live betting and
play-by-play
analysis it's fake headline Friday baby
you better join me in the member block
rest of the show continues now you don't
want to miss it become a member use code
NS at check out for 2 months free on all
annual
[Music]
plans